SEGMENTS.
ALL RIGHT I'M LAURA INGRAHAM
THIS IS THE INGRAHAM ANGLE FROM
WASHINGTON TONIGHT.
KNIVES OUT THAT'S THE FOCUS OF
TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
>> ALL RIGHT, RECORD HIGH GAS
PRICES, MARKETS COLLAPSING, WITH
THE S&P ENTERING THE BEAR MARKET
TERRITORY, CHINA THREATENING WAR
OVER TAIWAN AND THE NUMBER ONE
ISSUE FACING AMERICANS?
WELL, WE TRIED TO WARN THEM.
>> FORMER CLINTON TREASURE
SECRETARY LARRY SUMMERS HAS BEEN
WARNING ABOUT THE DARK CLOUDS
FORMING OVER THE BIDEN ECONOMY
FOR MONTHS.
DATA ARE POINTING MORE TOWARDS
HIGHER INFLATION.
>> THESE ARE SIMPLY NOT SERIOUS
PEOPLE.
IF THEY WERE THEY WOULD INVITE
LARRY SUMMERS TO THE WHITE HOUSE
TO GIVE THE ENTIRE CABINET AND
SENIOR STAFF LIKE RON KLAIN A
TUTORIAL IN BASIC ECONOMICS.
EVERY SINGLE PERSON ON HIS
ECONOMICS TEAM SHOULD BE FIRED.
IN FACT, ANYONE WHO ADVISED THE
PRESIDENT THAT INFLATION WAS
TRANSITORY SHOULD RESIGN OR BE
TERMINATED.
>> BUT JOE BIDEN AND WHATEVER
COMBO OF JILL, HIS SISTER AND
HUNTER HAVE KEPT THE WHOLE PLATE
THINGS SPINNING THESE PAST 18
MONTHS, THEY'RE REFUSING TO
BUDGE ON POLICY OR PERSONNEL.
THEY DECIDED JUST, I DON'T KNOW,
DENY REALITY AS LONG AS
POSSIBLE.
>> I SEE IMPORTANT TRANSITORY
INFLUENCES AT WORK, AND I DON'T
ANTICIPATE THAT IT WILL BE
PERMANENT.
>> MOST OF THE PRICE INCREASES
WE'VE SEEN WERE EXPECTED AND ARE
EXPECTED TO BE TEMPORARY.
>> IS IT WRONG TO CONSIDER
INFLATION TRANSITORY?
>> WE HAVE TO ADDRESS THE FACT
THAT WE GOT TO DEAL WITH THE
FACT THAT FOLKS ARE PAYING FOR
GAS, PAYING FOR GROCERIES AND
ARE, ARE -- NEED SOLUTIONS TO
IT.
>> IF WE WANT TO GET INFLATION
DOWN, I THINK CONTINUING TO MAKE
PROGRESS AGAINST THE PANDEMIC IS
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING WE CAN
DO.
>> Laura: THAT'S MY FAVORITE AT
THE END.
NO MATTER HOW MUCH AMERICANS
WERE AND ARE SUFFERING, NO
MATTER HOW LOW BIDEN SINKS IN
THE POLLS, THE WHITE HOUSE WOULD
NOT AND WILL NOT CHANGE COURSE.
>> WHAT IS THE GRAND PLAN TO
INCREASE OIL PRODUCTION IN
AMERICA?
>> HA HA.
THAT IS HILARIOUS, IF I HAD THE
MAGIC WAND ON THIS.
>> Laura: IF VOTERS HAD A MAGIC
WAND THEY'D WANT TO MAKE HER
DISAPPEAR FROM THE CABINET.
THEIR STEADFAST REFUSAL TO
CHANGE COURSE DESPITE THE
ONGOING DAMAGE TO THE AMERICAN
FAMILY IS REALLY THE DEFINITION
OF FANATICISM.
NOW, REMEMBER, THEY'VE CONVINCED
THEMSELVES THAT THE REASONS
VOTERS ARE UNHAPPY IS ONLY
BECAUSE THEIR MESSAGE HASN'T
BEEN ABLE TO BREAK THROUGH YET.
SO SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUES, THAT'S A
COMES PROBLEM.
$120 TO FILL YOUR TANKS OR SUV
THAT'S COMES PROBLEM.
NO BABY FORMULA THAT'S BAD PR.
BIDEN EVEN HITTING THE PRESS AT
THIS POINT.
WHY DON'T THEY PUBLIC SIZE ALL
THE GOOD HE'S DONE FOR AMERICA?
>> THERE'S A LOT OF MAJOR THINGS
WE'VE DONE BUT WHAT WE HAVEN'T
DONE IS WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
COMMUNICATE IT IN A WAY THAT IS,
UM -- LET ME SAY IT ANOTHER WAY.
>> SEE, THAT'S KIND OF PERFECT,
YEAH, HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
COMMUNICATE IT.
>> BUT LOOK AT HOW THE PRESS IS
CHANGED.
EVERYTHING GETS SENSATIONAL ICED
IN WAYS -- BUT I'M CONVINCED WE
CAN GET THROUGH THIS.
>> Laura: HOW INCREDIBLY
INSULTING TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THIS IS SENSATIONALIZED.
>> JUST TO GET TO SCHOOL AND
HOME EVERY SINGLE DAY IT'S
COSTING US $115 A WEEK.
>> IT'S PAINFUL TO GO THE GAS
STATION.
>> I NEED JESUS AND ALL OTHER
THINGS TO COME HELP ME.
IT'S TOO MUCH.
>> Laura: HIS POLICIES ARE
INFLICTING REAL PAIN ON REAL
PEOPLE.
AND HE EXPECTS THAT NO ONE'S
GOING TO REPORT ON IT?
THE FACT IS, THEIR AGENDA,
THOUGH, IS WORKING AS PLANNED
ISN'T IT?
IN ORDER TO HIT THEIR CLIMATE
CHANGE TARGET, RESET CAPITALISM
AS KLAUS SCHWAB FROM THE WORLD
ECONOMIC FORUM PUT IT, AMERICANS
MUST BECOME POORER, PERIOD.
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT'S
HAPPENING NOW.
THE VENDETTA AGAINST DOMESTIC
OIL PRODUCTION AND THE DESIRE
FOR OPEN BOARDERS, THE WAR IN
UKRAINE, MORE PRINTING OF MORE
MONEY, MORE BORROWING, MORE
RACIAL REINCRIMINATIONS, THEY'RE
DOING EXACTLY WHAT THEY'RE
DESIGNED TO DO.
USHER IN A NECESSARY PERIOD OF
AMERICAN DECLINE.
SO THE EUROPEAN MODEL OF HIGH
GAS PRICES, MORE GOVERNMENT
SPENDING, LESS PERSONAL FREEDOM,
THAT WAS ALWAYS THEIR PREFERRED
PATH.
BECAUSE IT WAS CONSIDERED FAR
SUPERIOR TO ANYTHING THAT
TRADITIONAL AMERICAN APPROACH
COULD OFFER.
SO THIS FAR LEFT VIEWPOINT, ONCE
LIMITED TO COLLEGE CAMPUSES NOW
DEFINES THE DEMOCRAT PARTY.
NOW, AS THE ANGLE PREDICTED
DURING THE CAMPAIGN OF 2020, A
FEEBLE MINDED GRIFTER LIKE JOE
BIDEN, HE WAS TOO WEAK OR TOO
STUPID TO RESIST THIS MORE
RIDICULOUS LEFT WING PASS FOR A
MORE SENSIBLE ONE.
BUT EVEN AFTER JOE BIDEN DID
EVERYTHING THEY ASKED, SUPPORTED
EVERY IDIOTIC GROWTH KILLING
POLICY THE LEFT PUSHED, THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE STILL PULLED THE
SWITCH BLADE ON HIM.
SINCE THEY CAN'T BLAME THEIR OWN
POLICIES FOR BRINGING RUIN TO
THE AVERAGE AMERICAN, THEY, TOO,
BELIEVE IT'S ALL A PR PROBLEM.
AND IF IT'S A PR PROBLEM, THEY
NEED A BETTER MESSENGER IN 2024
FOR THEIR SOCIAL AND POLITICAL
REVOLUTION.
BOTH THE OLD AND THE NEW GUARD
ARE TOSSING BIDEN TO THE CURB,
EVEN BEFORE THE MIDTERMS.
DAVID AXLE ROD TOLD THE NEW YORK
TIMES THE PRESIDENCY IS DEMON
TRATIVELY TAXING JOB AND THE
REALITY IS THE PRESIDENT WOULD
BE CLOSER TO 90 THAN 80 IN A
SECOND TERM AND THAT IS A MAJOR
ISSUE.
HERE'S WHAT HAPPENED WHEN AOC
WAS PRESSED ABOUT 2024.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN IS SAYING HE
IS GOING TO RUN AGAIN IN 2024.
WILL YOU SUPPORT HIM.
>> IF THE PRESIDENT CHOOSES TO
RUN AGAIN IN 2024, I MEAN, FIRST
OF ALL, I'M FOCUSED ON WINNING
THIS MAJORITY RIGHT NOW AND
PRESERVING A MAJORITY THIS YEAR
IN 2022.
SO WE'LL CROSS THAT BRIDGE WHEN
WE GET TO IT.
>> THAT'S NOT A YES.
>> YEAH, YOU KNOW, I THINK WE
SHOULD ENDORSE WHEN WE GET TO
IT.
BUT I BELIEVE THAT THE PRESIDENT
HAS BEEN DOING A VERY GOOD JOB
SO FAR AND, YOU KNOW, SHOULD HE
RUN AGAIN, I THINK THAT, I, YOU
KNOW, I -- WE'LL TAKE A LOOK AT
IT.
HA HA.
>> Laura: TRY TO DIAGRAM THAT
SENTENCE.
EVEN HIS OWN PRESS SECRETARY
DOESN'T FEEL COMFORTABLE TALKING
ABOUT BIDEN'S REELECTION
CAMPAIGN.
>> IS THE PRESIDENT RUNNING FOR
REELECTION?
>> HE HAS -- FIRST OF ALL, LET'S
RESET FOR A SECOND.
I CANNOT TALK ABOUT ELECTIONS.
THE PRESIDENT, AS YOU KNOW, HAS
BEEN ASKED THAT QUESTION MANY
TIMES.
HIS ANSWER HAS BEEN PRETTY
SIMPLE WHICH IS YES.
>> Laura: OKAY.
THIS IS ALL JUST AN EPIC CAST
OFF.
SO THIS IS WHAT I'M TELLING YOU
TONIGHT.
WELCOME TO THE LAME DUCK
ADMINISTRATION.
AND BIDEN AND HIS FAMILY ARE
SOMEHOW, I GUESS, SURPRISED BY
THIS?
HAD HE WORKED WITH REPUBLICANS,
TAKEN A MORE MODERATE APPROACH,
HE WOULD BE MORE POPULAR WITH
AMERICA BUT HE WOULD HAVE
ALIENATED THE RADICAL AND
POWERFUL FORCES IN HIS OWN
PARTY.
HE COULDN'T DO THAT.
FOR A SNEAK PEEK INTO THE
DEMOCRATS POLICY AND APPROACH,
LOOK NO FURTHER THAN THE
JANUARY 6TH HEARINGS TODAY.
NOW, WE COULDN'T HELP BUT NOTICE
THE BOTTOM RIGHT-HAND CORNER OF
THE SCREEN WHERE A GRAPHIC WAS
SHOWING THE BOTTOM FALLING OUT
OF THE MARKET.
SO AS AMERICANS STRUGGLE IN
2022, THE DEMOCRATS CAN'T STOP
TALKING ABOUT 2020.
>> AN ATTACK ON THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE BY TRYING TO ROB YOU OF
YOUR VOICE IN OUR DEMOCRACY AND,
IN DOING SO, LIT THE FUSE THAT
LED TO THE HORRIFIC VIOLENCE OF
JANUARY 6TH.
>> THEY MARCHED ON THE CAPITOL
AT HIS REQUEST.
AND HUNDREDS OF THEM BESIEGED
AND INVADED THE BUILDING AT THE
HEART OF OUR CONSTITUTIONAL ROW
PUP LICK.
>> Laura: OH, MY GOD PLAY THAT
AND THEY'LL GET ALL THE
INFORMATION THEY WANT.
EVEN THE MEDIA KNOWS THIS
DOESN'T HELP THEM.
>> EVEN IF IT DOESN'T CHANGE
PEOPLE'S VOTES IN THE MIDTERM
ELECTION, DEMOCRATS THINK THIS
IS AN EXTENSIONAL CRISIS IN
DEMOCRACY.
WHEN I GO OUT AND TALK TO
PEOPLE, THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE TELL
ME THEY'RE REALLY FOCUSED ON.
GAS PRICES AND ALL THE DIFFERENT
THINGS THAT ARE MAKING LIFE MORE
EXPENSIVE FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE.
AMERICANS AREN'T FOCUSED ON
THESE HEARINGS THE WAY WE ARE,
THAT DOESN'T MEAN --
>> Laura: THAT DOESN'T MEAN --
CHECK OUT THE NEW PICK AND ROLL.
BIDEN'S APPROVAL RATING SANCTION
TO ITS LOWEST LEVEL WITH
INVESTMENT BUSINESS DAILY WITH
36% OF AMERICAN ADULTS APPROVING
HOW HE'S HANDLING THE PRESIDENCY
AND 90% OF AMERICANS ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE PATH OF
INFLATION OVER THE NEXT 12
MONTHS, 53% ALREADY THINK WE'RE
IN A RECESSION.
YET, AGAIN, THE DEMOCRATS
PERSIST.
NO PERSONNEL CHANGES.
NO POLICY CHANGES.
RIDE THIS LAME HORSE OF BIG
GOVERNMENT, BIG GREEN SOCIALISM
RIGHT INTO MIDTERM OBLIVION.
I WAS THINKING ABOUT THIS TODAY.
MAYBE THE DEMOCRATS TRULY
BELIEVE THEY CAN CONVINCE
AMERICANS TO ACCEPT A LOWER
STANDARD OF LIVING.
AFTER ALL FOR DECADES CORRUPT
LEADERSHIP HAS PLAGUED CITIES
LIKE BALTIMORE, DETROIT, THESE
CITIES KEEP VOTING FOR DEMOCRATS
ELECTION CYCLE AFTER ELECTION
CYCLE.
SO WHEN WILL IT END?
THE TRUTH IS THOUGH DEMOCRATS
WON'T CHANGE.
THEY WON'T JETSON THE FAR LEFT
UNTIL THEY'RE FORCED TO.
BILL CLINTON WAS SMART ENOUGH TO
PIVOT IN 1994.
THAT DEMOCRAT PARTY THOUGH HAS
LONG SINCE BEEN BURIED.
IN 2024, THEY'RE GOING TO NEED
TO SUFFER A 1984 STYLE WIPEOUT
IN ORDER FOR US TO RESTORE
AMERICA.
AND WHETHER THEY RUN MAYOR PETE
OR AMY KLOBUCHAR OR KAMALA, IT'S
NOT GOING TO MATTER.
THEIR CORE POLICIES WILL NOT
CHANGE.
AND THE OUTCOME FOR AMERICAN
TAXPAYERS, FOR SENIORS, FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE, WILL BE THE SAME.
DESPAIR AND DECLINE.
ONLY WITH A N